you've mentioned that you enjoy the word
why my favorite word okay yeah how
should a writer incorporate the word why
and that never-ending curiosity from the
minute they start writing well that's a
great question um I mean why is
connected to curiosity and I think all
great artists are highly curious
individuals for me I'm just I'm just
curious about everything so the reason I
love writing so much is because you know
just like learning about it something I
mean I I'm not the first one to say this
but I write about things that fascinated
me because I don't know I don't know
about them and I was I write in order to
learn I write in order to learn more
about a topic and you know answer that
why question why is this done or how
whatever so but the why in terms of
writing connects to the reason why
characters do what they do
that's what audiences really want to
know and that comes to motivation
so what emission is really important I
mean it's the cliche actors a question
right like what's my motivation why do i
why am i doing this why am i think this
in a scene well when you're writing a
story and you're creating a character
and you have all these things happening
in the story that you've come up with so
again you want to do this is that and
this is going to happen you got to know
why audiences really want to know why
because if it's if it doesn't connect to
a universal motivation it's going to
feel contrived and fake and that happens
all the time what happens with you go
down you know what that character would
not do that what you know when you might
be true about that you know so for me
why connects to motivation you know it's
like once I know what a character wants
the next question is why and you better
have a good answer to why a character
wants what they want why did they react
a certain way you know which creates the
plot so comes to character it's all
psychology you know have you ever seen a
writer that maybe their curiosity could
be
ramped up a couple notches like they
just seem to you know there are certain
people that don't want to admit to ever
being wrong or not knowing something
yeah and they need a little little more
of that yeah
well depends of course I mean this is
just like any type of character or human
that you let you need I mean there's
people who are very curious any people
are totally non curious yeah you know
and and you can tell just by some people
who ask questions your usual people who
ask questions I mean when I meet
somebody new I mean on constantly ask
questions because I want to know I want
to know everything you know what a
person's almost completely asking
question but you know if somebody asks
you questions to that shows their
curiosity you know so it's really am and
you know curiosity is not a trait that
it's in every human being
although I feel it should but they're
curious about certain things and they're
less curious about others and it depends
on the human being really so how does
that show up in the writing and maybe
another very serious but it depends I
think it goes to how original the
writing is how much of a world is
explored right because you know somebody
was not really curious about something
it'll be flat because you only get like
it's just a certain level of material
right whether it's one-dimensional
characters right they just like one
surface of a character codes that you
didn't go deeper as to the research or
knowing about that character or their
psychology so that's I feel I feel like
that you know when you come across
stories that are really rich and deep
you can tell the writer was very curious
because they you know they dug deep and
that's what they explored so Silence of
the Lambs perfect example yeah I mean
look at all the richness of detailed
character character psychology in that
world The Godfather
perfect example
yeah I mean justjust you can tell the
artists that are really curious about
the world they're writing and the
characters you know those who really
write truly true three-dimensional
characters and great complex
relationships and you know yeah so
that's that's how it affects it you know
and not everybody is curious so that's
why you have good writers and bad
writers
you